as you guys knew in a special friendship
well
[Laughter]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the vlog where
I have terrible lighting and I still
don't know what to do my PhD so normally
when I vlog I like to start pretty early
in the day and kind of like get the ball
rolling it's like 8:00 p.m. I have been
editing all day those of you who have
watched the previous vlog wonder that I
was away basically all of last week in
Edinburgh and at Warhammer world and now
finally coming back and finishing off
this video on black holes which I've
just been desperate to do last week he
wasn't so nearly done I spent all of
today working on it and I think I've
just done the last bit this timeline is
pretty dense there's like a lot of
graphics going on here there's all these
red things After Effects compositions
some of which I did my first 3d work on
this like this is definitely the most
complicated thing I've done in After
Effects it's still pretty simple but it
took me quite a long time to work out
how to do all the various 3d bits oh
hello
so now I just need to do the final audio
mix so that's all the dialogue has been
done you know I've recorded that ages
ago now it's getting music underneath
and making it all work slickly and then
I am uploading it and making sure I have
the approval of the sponsor and then
we're a away last so this week this
video is going to be coming out I'm
gonna be making a push to do more vlogs
we've also got a special trip this week
actually there's two special trips this
week one I am the recipient of because
dan from loads of previous videos it's
coming here the Emperor is coming here
we shall double our efforts and we're
recording a bunch of stuff for Spungen
electric it's my second channel which
you might not know about because we
don't really put anything on there apart
from the wiki cast that's gonna change
we are gonna be putting some stuff on
there soon that's happening and then
also I've got a wedding to go to next
week which my friend Joe he met in the
last blog
we were playing Warhammer together for a
stag - he's getting married and pixel
girl is coming with me so I get to see
my girlfriend again so that something
has been confirmed actually that she can
come so I am a very happy boy right now
having retired this is gonna be an
interesting week not very much
interesting happening today although
well just ignore that that's that's fine
I have this bad boy which I just used to
record a some pick up audio for the
black holes video this is a direct audio
interface which means I can use my vocal
in here at my shotgun and I can now
record them directly into the computer
which means I can now seriously look at
streaming probably the delay between the
Vlachs coming out and like the reality
of them happening is enough that maybe
this has already happened but that's
something I've been wanting to do for a
long time that also makes like recording
podcast and is easier but and it's one
of those things where it's like quite
nice like I've been I've had my eye on
it for a while I just was like right
save up next month we've had a lot of
expenses coming out this month it's like
next month we're gonna get that and it's
gonna like level up and it's it's like
almost like in a game we'll let you get
the item to advance you to the next
level it's like yeah I'm so much more
powerful because of this and then of
course it's like well what about the
next item but this right here is a
powerup for me right now it's kind of
cool to see the the progression so
speaking of progression Pollock is don't
judy bench
thanks to Helen Arne for sending us
Alex's t-shirt in fact he's rocking an
all-black look today
oh I mean we look like such gimmicks we
did not coordinate these t-shirts on /
phones so shout out to Helen Arne at the
festival spoken node Alex asked on
Twitter or free merch basically yeah we
were like if you want to send us keep
your t-shirts will wear them understand
you've got a dress with job you won
yeah you've got act like give me free
stuff because they think I'm someone so
this morning I'm sorting out food for
the next five days as part of go to the
gym keep part of it I've always fallen
down on before it's nutrition and so
this means I have a regulated source of
meals which basically nutritionally
balanced lots of protein not that many
calories not an emphasis on carbs it's
brown rice vegetables and them is gonna
be Cod coming in it's like an industry I
lie doing this it's actually quite
liberating because it means that you
just don't worry about food so the other
thing which I did this morning was
finalized
the kind of release version of a black
hole video what I do when I make a video
is do a few notes that's why I keep
these on my desk so there are a few
things to tweak which aren't necessarily
obvious when you're editing I've become
very obvious when you MC it online so
I'm gonna do that you're gonna get a
sponsor approval and then finally come
out and that's out I'm not gonna move on
to the blog there's actually two vlogs
fully in the can and behind I wonder can
I get up to date with that I also do
some contract work for some other people
yeah it's just it's not to do I feel a
little bit overwhelmed at the moment
from honest but I always would rather
have slightly too much 30 then not quite
enough now we're gonna watch some
terrible YouTube and eat
hello oh hey I didn't see you enter in
this totally natural candid shot I'm
kind of upside down let's fix that so
it's about ten o'clock I have been
editing all day
I've actually now just been waiting for
approval to post this video which is
kind of one of the things about having
sponsors there's now another link in the
chain one of the main advantages of
being a youtuber is that you can be an
individual creator with an audience of I
mean not millions in my case if you're
KZ nice day yeah but as soon as you
start involving brands then you know you
do have to get it through sort of check
through people so I'm basically waiting
for that so I've been doing a little bit
contract work I'm doing some videos for
another podcast it's actually a really
interesting podcast I'll leave a link
below to this podcast which is about
translation translating literature I've
been doing that and I'm gonna be
finishing up this one and then actually
getting an early night because I am
severely sleep-deprived and I haven't
had any energy really to vlog today
which is why I haven't really vlog today
this shot is surprisingly cool oh no
it's like I'm filming vertical oh cool
okay oh it's like a very huge selfie
stick stick selfie stick the Black Hills
video is finally out oh my god they're
late another
open oh look it's that boy my god
it's Daniel it's just like the olden
time so Saddam is hit we're about to
record a wiki cast with the same
technology that we used for the first
it's not like it's like a different age
like you learn a songs period yeah the
same technology but we're in the same
room whereas now we do it separately
dance came up to shoot a video because I
haven't actually showed them this in the
vlog so by the time this comes out this
will still be available we're doing wiki
cast shirts own shirt a clip of Dan
modeling one lusciously now so we're
recording a video for that which means
we're both here and I needed a small
model because the t-shirt we have is a
small and it's a bit too small for me so
it's like I know it's like that picture
of us drove the picture of us right yeah
I'll put that in the video as well it's
like that all over again Dan's back here
we're recording the Wiggy cars but we
don't like looking at Iike this is weird
we're so used to not seeing each other
when we record now that we just tried to
start the podcaster we've got staring
each other okay so now Dan's got this
witsec show of me where you can see my
silhouette so podcasts recording over
we're now I'm modeling making down model
for me because we are we're doing the
advert which you probably have seen by
now
now the other four these t-shirts we now
need to take the clothes off for this
next shot well Simon Simon cover means
stickers of our faces this is the
perfect exercise in light narcissism
it's great it's perfect
the facial recognition is like what the
yeah yeah that's too many people
again the music doesn't really add to
these and intensity does it
[Music]
so we just finished recording the video
for these two chumpy t-shirts we're now
going to try and live stream this should
do my first ever live stream on twitch
because Dan's here and we may as well
masquerade under the fat Oh oh my god
it's working it's a thing why it was
that one so loud it sounds like the
Superman theme Python yeah
here we go right okay let's let's see if
we can make this work uh-huh right time
to support the family business
semi pair of formal shoes basically fell
apart literally the soles came away from
the leather and I'm going to a wedding
this week so it's time for me to get
some new ones isn't it so much different
a black shoes this is not going to be
difficult I love how my life is
basically spent entirely in my studio so
every time I leave it's like oh let's do
some you know run for editing for this
one try and make it look interesting
let's not involve some shoes guys my
life is not interesting I nearly said
this is why I can be a daily vlogger he
says in his daily blog I said it before
and I'll say it again I'm not a smart
man now I just need to find that he's a
six year old man there's an MS right
here he's only gonna be looking at
stocks or at wine knew it okay so yes
that it was fun it was actually really
fun to kind of share the creative space
with somebody like like Dan who you know
we just made will be out by now the
advert for the merchandise which was
just completely improvised like it's
really fun
and the same with Alex like being able
to do stuff with with other Creators
like when I'm so used to being on my own
it's really really fun to just kind of
bounce ideas off of people it's
something that have a plan in a long
long distant future that maybe will one
day come to fruition
it'll be based around that but that's
like years away so so far today I have
been editing that video for the
merchandise which took a little bit
longer than I expected because I kind of
wanted it to deepen with with a few
effects hopefully it kind of showed
through it's just it was just a fun
thing to edit and and whilst that's
rendering I have been updating the store
part on my website because that's now a
thing
I was actually chatting to people in
there's like a group chat and
with a bunch of other youtubers chat to
people about this about like the whole
idea of merchandise and commodifying
yourself and your appearance because I'm
trying to consciously wherever I can
move away from having my face and
thumbnails because I feel uncomfortable
commodifying my appearance for one thing
it doesn't feel earned like also I think
most importantly I've always had this
belief and I've always been taught this
belief that people Bank in on their
appearance are narcissistic in vain and
perhaps I have a slight Disney Prince
mentality about this whole thing but I
don't want to be either of those things
so I've always very consciously tried to
not
yeah like modifying myself based on the
things I represent like being a PhD
student being a scientist you know being
like a youtuber all these ideas I have a
problem with forming an identity and
kind of almost selling me as a product
based on those but appearance is
different appearance is kind of strange
and as a friend Brian pointed out like
you know you do have a t-shirt with your
face on now which is really straight
like that's still strange to me but
that's like stylized and it's it's not
just me it's a it's like Dan line as a
pair I don't have such a problem with
that I think the idea of just having me
like my face on a t-shirt especially if
it's that face that's not gonna be a
good look
I don't want to be that guy and I hope
that people call me out if I ever become
that guy I mean look at me I look at its
lighting I clay don't care about my
appearance
any star today I kept waking up like
every hour it was so paranoid about
being late so Alex and I didn't want to
miss a session this week and so we are
after 20 minutes at 6:04 we have you
eaten anything
no the only thing that I am focused is
pre-workout okay
well it looks like everyone else is
having exactly the same idea it's 6:00
a.m.
well that was fun probably get - I've
gotta get to the lab got a gift okay bye
okay last the day today 9:30 a.m. and
I've already been editing for like an
hour this is the blog from like two
weeks ago I'm really conscious I'm
behind on the vlog so I literally have I
think two full ones in the can and then
I'm obviously this week's one done
ideally I want to be editing these blogs
at the end of each day just kind of cut
everything together rather than doing
everything in one big going but yeah
having one those days were actually
enjoying editing which is just as well
so the blog is now edited and currently
uploading my internet speed is like 1.5
up so it's this is nearly 50 minutes
this blog it's bigger blog because it's
the one that's got the discussion with
penny in that's like 17 minutes or
something down at the blog and then like
the wrote the vlog kind of really starts
I didn't want to compromise on that like
for one thing I promised it was gonna
happen I'm damn sure gonna put it in and
then also I think it was worth putting
in in basically full there just a couple
of cuts just when stuff happened that
you know wasn't wasn't contributing
wasn't stuff that penny had said it was
like background noise something like
real oudh clanging and we had to redo
stuff so it's gonna take a while
and I just wanted to sort of talk about
in the vlog I mentioned that like just
before filming I'm like well all this
effort it's gonna be good as long as it
doesn't some wasn't you know flop of
course I have like two weeks later when
I actually released it definitely
flopped I II would consider a video a
success if it got more than 20,000 views
in its first 24 hours it would be a
great success it was more than 30,000
views in the first 24 hours the vlog so
no plug the black holes video got less
than 10,000 24 hours and I think the
issue is that whilst the video itself I
think is one of my best and all of the
comments on it have been fantastic
they're all all of the comments have
been uniformly positive about how much
people enjoyed it
you know so great it means I made
something good it I think what that
tells me is that it was a topic either
it was a topic or ID marketed it in such
a way that was not appealing to a mass
audience and it comes back to this whole
like measure of artistic integrity right
do you make stuff that you think is good
but you know the best stuff that doesn't
get seen by many people like art house
cinema like objectively just better
films they get seen by nobody or do you
make stuff that has less intellectual
content that has less individual worth
but get seen by loads of people so
transformers basically don't want this
channel to be like whiplash or like
transformers like obviously I want it to
be like whiplash I think that there's I
don't want to make stuff that is just
bland and populist however at the same
time I have to be able to eat and you
know make enough money from from making
videos this is stuff this is what stuff
like patreon is super important and
that's not a plug that's literally just
me saying that I think that that is that
is a really important reason the patreon
to exist you know supporting people that
are making stuff that might it's either
low volume there's not very much of it
but it's very high quality or it's stuff
that it's very niche in very specific
and I realized that the kind of videos
like I'm moving into which is science
and specifically doing quite a few in
the history of science they are quite
niche and you know that having the
direct support from patrons on patreon
is super super important way of making
sure that you can do that that said of
course there's a way to market and title
and thumbnail videos which are very
niche but you make people wanna click on
them and I feel like I really hit that
on the head with the video I did on what
books to read if you wanna study physics
for example that's done so well was
really easy to produce was was filmed in
very short time was like the simplest
thing to edit in the world and how it
currently has more than 10 times the
views of the black hole video which was
definitely more than 10 times the work
so there's a factor of a hundred
difference in terms of work and outcome
in terms of you know revenue but also
impressions you know actually people
seeing the thing so I think what I need
to do my objective as a youtuber at this
stage is to get better optimizing my
content not necessarily changing what I
make or at least not the topics that I'm
working at but trying to angle them in
such a way that gets more people
interested some people are really good
at this like some people are excellent
at doing titles and thumbnails that just
make you want to click I am NOT one
those people it's a weakness of mine
I don't like weaknesses so I better
destroy it if you wonder why I've got
into this habit of like vlogging on the
floor the floors really underrated
there's a place of comfort for one thing
but also I am so tired like oh my god I
do not keep myself in our sleep when
we're doing tonight I'm editing to lay
the wiki cast isn't gonna suck itself
wait supposed to be they didn't see the
last one I make sure he's getting
married
[Music]
he does he get married quite place that
came through the tree
nobody gotta get some come from
[Music]
oh my god you look so nice so we're now
here for Joe's wedding with she still
pixelated but she looks really really
nice thanks we'll go this is kind of
grand I never doubted your ability
[Music]
so I should explain that Jay doesn't
live here and his bride doesn't live his
wife now doesn't live here this is a
really nice venue called heading and
Castle which they just picked and it's
really really really nice but yeah they
don't they can't afford a place that is
quite yet
[Music]
so after the wedding I've got a day in
Cambridge
we're here in hommerson which is bixell
girls college doing work basically which
for me has been catching up on emails
because even I'm just been out of the
office for like a day or two days and
being away from YouTube stats and emails
built up and what's become clear is that
the vlog went life which was the vlog
talking about racism exited my friend
penny and also the video getting much
announcing much and the match has gone
very way better than I expected like at
the moment we're about 90 orders in
which is literally twice as many as I
thought we'd get in the whole pre-order
run so that's been an amazing success
and what's also clear is that people
haven't really liked the vlog very much
now I want to be clear that I'm not
trying to make one of those videos where
it's just like me going
because I am not automatically entitled
to have an audience that likes
everything I do of course there are
going to be some things which you making
people just don't like they're going to
dislike it a lot of people sudden
subscribe the past two days between the
merge video in this video I probably
lost out on several hundred subscribers
normally I gain a few hundred a day and
yesterday I gained twenty so like you
know it has been a big big cull of
people from from the channel which
together with the the lack of use and
the number of dislikes is obviously
quite discouraging but at the same time
this is a topic that the various ism
discussed in that video is a naturally
polarizing topic that I have not really
talked about in the vlog before you know
the merch stuff is definitely aimed at a
particular subset of the audience people
the really you like the stuff I make and
I'm honestly blown away by the fact that
about the people that really do that we
made that video for have loved it like
and I've been like yes please like I
want I want t-shirts now that's
obviously incredible but like yeah
naturally the people the other end
especially when I might subscribe to
this so the unsubscribe which I can
completely understand
you can't help get a little bit
disparaged when a lot of people take a
look at something you've made and
they're like Anna and I think this has
played into just generally over the past
couple of weeks you know I didn't
release anything for a while because I
was away and because I was working on
the black hole video and I was like yeah
this videos going to do so so well I
think it's really interesting I think
it's pretty well made when I released it
the people that did watch it
I've loved it really really lovely
comments fantastic likes the dislike
ratio you know couldn't be happier after
that it's just that people aren't
clicking it and it did feel a little bit
like oh okay that's you know all that
work is gone into not very much okay
nevermind and then you release a vlog
and it doesn't really get that many
views and you lose a whole bunch of
subscribers and you know this is like
I'm worrying about a couple of hundred
subscribers and a 90% light ratio as
opposed to you know the 120,000 people
who are subscribed to the channel and
normally a 99% like to dis light ratio
like it's like the youtuber version of
first world problems but at the end of
the day I am human and these things
these starts are way down on you and
again I want to be very clear I am NOT
trying to make a video that that's like
what I'm saying in the series which is
as far as I can tell like an honest
video blog of what it's like living my
life
trying to finish off the PhD trying to
work out what to do with the PhD and
make videos and just generally try make
a positive contribution with the
academic skills that I've been given in
that sense of ever being an honest
record and oh this is it's this thing is
affecting me in a negative way I guess I
am whining but I'm also realizing the
limitations of like the impact of what
this is actually going to have on me
what I definitely now need to do is just
a little take stock and be like yeah
you've had a couple of videos now quite
a while there haven't done very well the
last video I did which did really well
was the physics reading video about you
know read these books if you want to
study physics I think I basically in
line with what I said earlier this week
in terms of like balancing what I want
to make and what's actually going to get
views I need to take a long look at how
I can balance it and what I can do that
is in both camps that is a positive
contribution to the universe and you
know is going to get people interested
because it's very possible to do that
I've done that before and I've just got
to sort of look at what I've got planned
what's coming and then say you know how
can how can we make this better this is
this so failure has like motivated me
because this is you know the angle of
being a youtuber is to be watched right
it's to make stuff that people watch
that people like and if people want to
subscribe and recently opened making
stuff the people haven't watched people
with dislike and it's made them
unsubscribe so to me at the moment you
could argue is a weeding and it's like
getting rid of people who I wouldn't
want watching me anyway and some of the
comments on the vlog have definitely
been of that nature but I think it's in
kind of constructed to view this as a
because you then say right off of that
how can I improve this is now a
motivation to do better so that's
basically where I'm at today
this is an opportunity also John Hammond
there's neither guy from Jurassic Park
the voice you're hearing in John anyway
I've wondered like the length of
Hamilton College which as you can see is
the kind of under reconstruction but
very nice College a lot of green gonna
stand out like it's known as being a
very postgraduate heavy College in
Cambridge but it's been nice can't wait
to come here inside and I'm going to the
ball here which presumably coming on too
but yeah I should probably get back to
work and start right in the next video
which is gonna do well
[Music]